ja willkommen zur heutigen Vorlesung
heute werden wir uns noch mal mit dem
Thema der letzten Sitzung befassen die
letzten Vorlesungen haben wir machen das
immer ein bisschen überlappend
der Rückblick in der letzten Sitzung
hatten wir uns befassen zum Thema was
ist Vernunft was ist praktische Vernunft
man kann es genauso fragen was ist
Rationalität
das ist die spannende Frage
also im Zentrum der heutigen
Vorlesung steht noch mal
der Begriff der Vernunft und wir hatten
uns überlegt es gibt verschiedene
Operationen also
Anwendungsweise der Vernunft wird
befassen uns natürlich nur mit der
praktischen Vernunft es gibt auch die
theoretische Vernunft theoretische
Vernunft ist etwas wenn Sie zum Beispiel
Schlüsse ziehen jetzt der Logik oder
wenn sie mathematisches Problem lösen
wenn sie etwas erkennen wollen und was
theoretischen Interesse ist dann
benutzen Sie die theoretische Vernunft
und wenn sie aber jetzt zum Beispiel
Schlüsse machen die ähm ihre Handeln
betreffen also wenn jetzt endlich die
Vernunft in all ihren Operationen auch
wir handeln bezogen ist dann nennt man
das die praktische Vernunft es gibt
jetzt verschiedene Operationen die kann
gleichermaßen die theoretische wie die
praktische Vernunft durchführen ist
immer auch problematisch von der
Vernunft so zu sprechen als ob sie etwas
täte das ist genauso das Problem mit dem
Willen der Wille tut etwas natürlich
schon Wille gar nichts sondern die
Person die wendet den Willen an auf die
ein oder andere Weise sie gebraucht ihre
Vermögen also der Wille und die Vernunft
und die Wahrnehmungsfähigkeit das sind
alles Vermögen das auch noch ein
wichtiger Begriff wir haben verschiedene
Vermögen in uns
man kann auch sagen Fähigkeit aber
häufig spricht man von Vermögen und der
Wille ist ein Vermögen und die Vernunft
ist eben auch ein Vermögen jetzt kann
man sich darüber
streiten wie bei so vielen Dingen der
Philosophie wie ist jetzt die Vernunft
zu verstehen gibt es zwei vernünftige
oder zwei vernünftige oder wie man es
nennen soll eine theoretische und eine
praktische oder gibt es nur eine und die
sind ihre Anwendung verschieden viele
spricht dafür dass es eine Vernunft gibt
dass sie einfach verschiedenartig
angewendet werden kann ja also wir
können eben alle Operationen auf das
theoretische richten auf unsere
theoretisches Interesse oder auf unser
praktisches Interesse und jetzt gibt's
zum Beispiel eine Operation vergleichen
das ist ganz klassischerweise eine
Vernunft Operation zum Beispiel sprechen
die Empiristen David jung den hatten wir
schon letzten Sitzung mal kurz behandelt
wir kommen heute auch noch drauf die
Imperialisten sagen die Vernunft besteht
darin unsere Vorstellungen miteinander
zu vergleichen ja also Ähnlichkeit
größer kleiner solche Vergleiche
durchzuführen und am Ende zu einem
Urteil zu kommen die sagen das ist jetzt
größer als das dass es ein eine Vernunft
Tätigkeit wir können auch abwägen wir
können Gründe in Erwägung ziehen Gründe
bewährten auch das kann eine Form der
praktischen 15 wir können und das wird
jetzt immer nur Kant wir können
verallgemeinern wir können zum Beispiel
uns überlegen ich habe jetzt einen
Grundsatz kann spricht von einer Maxime
wir werden dieses diesen Begriff heute
noch kennenlernen eine Maxim ich habe
einen Grundsatz und zwar immer wenn
immer wenn es wenn ich einen Bettler
deine Bettlerin sehe dann gebe ich ihr
zwei Euro das ist eine Maxime immer wenn
alle Fälle immer wenn und jetzt kann ich
diese Maxime verallgemeinern kann mich
fragen ähm kann ich das wirklich
vernünftigerweise wollen dass alle
Menschen diese Maxime haben ich gebe
noch eine andere Maxime die es
vielleicht ein bisschen problematischer
zum Beispiel die Maxime wenn ich in
einer gesellschaftlichen Situation
die Stimmung verbessern kann dann will
ich lüge dann will ich die Notlüge am
verwenden dann will ich mir eine
Ausnahme erlauben dann will ich damit
das Gegenüber nicht
gekränkt ist oder nicht peinlich berührt
ist es gibt ja immer Sie sind eingeladen
zum Essen
ihr bester Freund ihre beste Freundin
hat sie gekocht und das Essen schmeckt
nicht soll ja mal vorkommen und dann
fragt ihre Freundin ihr Freund sie und
und wie schmeckt es essen und die sagen
wirklich gut ja wirklich gut so dann
haben sie und es hat aber eigentlich
nicht gut geschmeckt dann haben sie eine
Notlüge
geäußert und viele Menschen mich
eingeschlossen zumindest momentan haben
die Maxime dass man lügen darf wenn es
dazu dient dass man einfach eine andere
Person nicht kennt ja und das ist eine
Maxim ist ein Grundsatz und jetzt können
wir uns aber Fragen ist dieser Grundsatz
wirklich
moralisch ja stichhaltig können wir
diesen Grundsatz
verallgemeinern ist dieser Grundsatz von
einer solchen Art das alle vernünftigen
Wesen ihn wollen könnten oder wollen
können sollten was würde passieren wenn
alle Menschen diese Maxime hätten
Immanuel Kant würde sagen das wäre nicht
gut also Notlüge ist keine gute Option
man kann würde sagen diese Maxime ist
eigentlich unmoralisch genug Lüge wir
kommen da auch noch mehr drauf zu
sprechen wenn es um Gut und Böse geht
ich persönlich bin ja mal Notlügen kann
man vernünftig verallgemeinern sofern
die Notlüge im Rahmen des ja ja das
Kontextes von privaten Unterhaltung
bleibt wenn ich natürlich die Lüge dann
ausdehne und dann sagt ach die Lüge kann
ich auch noch in anderen Kontext mehr
erlauben dann wird es natürlich
problematisch ja wenn ich mit zum
Beispiel die Maxime mache in allen
Situationen wo ich einen Vorteil davon
haben kann zu lügen dann sagt immer nur
kann und das finde ich jetzt zu Recht
dann können wir nicht vernünftigerweise
wollen verallgemeinernd das alle
Subjekte diese Maxime haben weil dann
würde uns ja niemand mehr glauben wir
könnten dann alles sagen und die andere
Person würde sagen woher weiß ich denn
dass du jetzt nicht mal wieder lügst
oder eine Notlüge oder sowas hier
anwendest und dann könnten wir gar nicht
mehr eine vernünftig
funktionierende Gesellschaft denken ja
darüber kann man natürlich auch noch
diskutieren aber das leuchtet ja
irgendwie schon ein also wenn jeder
Lügen dürfte wann und wann ihm oder ihr
es lieb ist dann funktioniert die
Gesellschaft nicht nur die Gesellschaft
dann macht Kommunikation überhaupt
keinen Sinn mehr und Handeln eigentlich
auch nicht also das ist ziemlich klar
mit der Lüge aber mit der Notlüge ist es
nicht so trivial Immanuel kann sagt
jedenfalls die Grenze zwischen normale
Lüge und Notlüge die ist nicht so klar
wenn wir einmal eine Notlüge zulassen
dann
passiert es ganz schnell dass wir auch
andere Situationen so interpretieren als
ob wir darin in Notlüge zulassen dürfen
wir haben einfach den Hang dazu und
deswegen sollten wir grundsätzlich nicht
lügen bin ich ein bisschen anderer
Meinung aber darüber kann man ganz ganz
treffend diskutieren das tun wir auch
noch wenn wir dann zum Thema Gut und
Böse kommen ich will nur sagen dieser
Gedanke kann meine Maxime vernünftig
verallgemeinert werden kann ich mir
widersprüchlich vorstellen
widerspruchsfrei vorstellen dass alle
Personen diese Maxime haben bei der Lüge
kann ich das nicht so leicht tun wenn
ich mir vorstelle alle würden irgendwann
immer ist in Recht ist dann würde keine
vernünftige Weltordnung mehr zustande
kommen und dieser diese Operation des zu
verallgemeinern zu denken was wäre wenn
alle so
dächten oder die Maxime hätten wie ich
diese Operation das ist auch eine
vernünftige Operation vor allgemeine und
sie kennen sicher diesen kategorischen
Imperativ wir kommen heute auch näher
drauf zu sprechen diese kategorischen
Imperativ der gebietet eben gerade
unsere Maximen unsere subjektiven
Handlungsgrundsätze wie zum Beispiel
wenn ich beim Abendessen eingeladen bin
und es schmeckt mir nicht dann möchte
ich dann werde ich lügen um die andere
Person nicht zu denken dass eine Maxime
und dieser kategorischen Imperativ der
fordert gerade unsere Maximen zu
allgemeinen und zu überprüfen und das
ist eben auch eine Operation unserer
praktischen Vernunft genauso ähnlich ist
es wenn wir etwas auf Widersprüche
hinprüfen letztendlich besteht der
maximentest des kategorisch Imperativs
auch darin dass wir verallgemeinern aber
damit auch letztendlich unsere Maxime
auf eine nicht ganz so leicht erkennbare
Widersprüchlichkeit oder wie
Widerspruchsfreiheit hin prüfen und auch
das ist eine Operation die unsere fünf
betrifft wir können natürlich auch
Formeln oder logische
logische
Formel oder logische Ausdrücke hin
prüfen ob sie widersprüchlich sind ja ob
da am Ende a und nun a rauskommt ja dann
haben wir ein Widerspruch das heißt wir
können sagt zumindest Kant wir können
unsere Handlungen oder Maximen genau
genommen auf Widersprüchlichkeit hin
prüfen und wir können natürlich auch in
theoretischer Hinsicht
logische Phänomene logische Schlüsse
oder so auf Widersprüchlichkeit hin
prüfen das heißt unsere Vernunft ist
einmal im theoretischen einmal im
praktischen Sinne aktiv wir können
natürlich auch analysieren das sind
jetzt nur ein paar Formen also in
kleinere Teile Fragen Probleme zerlegen
das ist eine Form der Vernunft und ganz
wichtig ist Schlüssel ziehen ne da wird
vielleicht die von uns am deutlichsten
sichtbar die Manuel kann sagt z.B dass
die Vernunft das Vermögen zu schließen
Zeit das lustig Vermögen also Vermögen
die ich schon sagte der Wille ist
einfach mögen nämlich das
begehrungsvermögen das haben sie schon
kennengelernt es gibt das untere
begehrungsvermögen traditionellerweise
es gibt das obere begehrungsvermögen
auch eine gute Frage für den Typ A der
Klausur was der Unterschied ist
traditionellerweise also
regierungsvermögen und es geht eben ein
Vernunft Vermögen und das ist
klassischerweise das Vermögen auch
Schlüssel zu ziehen
und zu urteilen manchmal spricht man
auch dann vom Vermögen zu urteilen
zumindest macht das immer nur kann von
der Urteilskraft also er unterscheidet
nochmal das Vermögen zu urteilen von dem
Vermögen zu schließen aber da kann man
auch groß darüber diskutieren welche
Vermögen man beim Menschen annehmen
möchte das ist eine spannende Frage aber
dass Sie einfach den Begriff des
Vermögens auch mal gehört haben die
Vernunft die praktische Vernunft ist ein
menschliches Vermögen neben dem
begehrungsvermögen gibt es das von uns
Vermögen und es gibt auch noch das
Wahrnehmung und traditioneller Weise
sagen viele Philosophen das Tiere nur
unteres begehrungsvermögen haben das
haben wir schon mal erklärt also
praktisch nur wantons sind mit Harry
friendford gesprochen praktisch nur
Wünsche erster Stufe haben keine
volition zweiter Stufe ausbilden können
und Tiere so die klassische Auffassung
die man natürlich auch problematisieren
muss Tiere hätten neben dem unteren
begehrungsvermögen noch ein
Wahrnehmungsvermögen das ist natürlich
klar ne Tiere müssen ja irgendwie
Sinnesempfindungen haben und danach dann
ihre begehrungen koordinieren aber ein
vernunftvermögen wird nicht menschlichen
Tieren oder Tieren häufig in der
Tradition der Philosophie abgesprochen
das ist natürlich auch problematisch ne
man kann ja darüber diskutieren ob nicht
auch Tiere eine bestimmte also nicht
menschliche Tiere eine Form eine
bestimmte Form von Rationalität besitzen
und zwar wäre das dieser Kandidat der
nicht menschlich tierischen Rationalität
der wäre die instrumentelle von uns also
angenommen ich möchte an einem Marathon
teilnehmen ich habe mir zum Ziel gesetzt
ich möchte jetzt gibt es ein Konstanz
ein Marathon ich glaube nicht oder aber
ein Halbmarathon vielleicht als
angenommen ich möchte in Konstanz
Halbmarathon erfolgreich absolvieren
sprich einfach nicht völlig außer pusten
Ziel gekommen sondern locker durchlaufen
wenn ich mir das zum Ziel setze was muss
ich dann machen dann kommt die
instrumentelle 5 und sagt wenn du das
willst der Zweck ist denn Konstanz
Halbmarathon in einer Stunde und 55 zu
laufen das ist
Anfänger ist es okay also für Anfänger
kann das eigene Erfahrung sagen ist es
gut wenn man Halbmarathon unter zwei
Stunden läuft das ist schon am Anfang ja
also ich will den Konstanz Halbmarathon
unter zwei Stunden laufen
das ist mein Zweck oder mein Ziel jetzt
muss die instrumentelle Vernunft mit das
richtige Ziel das richtige Mittel dafür
nennen und jetzt kann man sich überlegen
was wäre denn das richtige Mittel zum
Zweck den Konstanz Halbmarathon unter
zwei Stunden zu laufen ja da können Sie
jetzt überlegen ich habe so ein paar
Ideen zum Beispiel zweimal wöchentlich
10 km zocken und ein Trainingsplan
erstellen und auf die Ernährung achten
am Tag davor an der Pasta Party
teilnehmen also viel Kohlenhydrate zu
sich nehmen das gibt's nämlich immer für
diesen Events und ähm dann sich gut
vorbereiten gute Laufschuhe sich
besorgen auf das Wetter hin achten ob
das Wetter an diesem Tag gut ist ist die
Wettervorhersage dann muss man ja
unendlich viel Bedenken ja ist die
laufuhren in Ordnung funktioniert alles
wieder und so weiter so fort es ist nur
ein Beispiel es können Sie beliebig da
ihren Hobbys und so weiter können sich
das auch beliebig überlegen das heißt
ihre instrumentelle Vernunft sucht das
Mittel zum sagen das können verschiedene
Mittel sein es gibt nicht nur ein Mittel
zum erfolgreichen Konstanz Halbmarathon
sondern es gibt ganz viele Mittel die in
der Summe dann Ihnen vielleicht eine
gute Zeit garantieren da müssen sie ganz
viele Dinge bedenken sie müssen planen
sie müssen auch schon vorausblicken auch
das ist eine Form von Vernunft
Antizipation von möglichen Ereignissen
zum Beispiel könnte sein die
Wettervorhersage sagt an diesem Tag
wurde halt Marathon stattfindet ist
Regenwetter angesagt ja dann müssen sie
natürlich umdisponieren müssen schauen
ja wie bereite ich mich jetzt auf die
Situation am besten vor trage ich eine
andere Begleitung wasserabweisend aber
dann wird's mir wieder zu heiß was mache
ich jetzt so ja also so da werden sie
letztendlich auch der liberieren sie
werden hier natürlich auch irgendwie
Gründe mit einbeziehen was spricht dafür
als auch delebrieren das haben wir hier
schon gehabt
hingegen ist eine ganz typische
am Tätigkeit der praktischen Vernunft
und jetzt kann man natürlich sagen
instrumentelle Vernunft haben doch auch
Tiere ja und darüber diskutieren wir
jetzt gleich ein bisschen davor möchte
ich aber noch auf diese Frage eingehen
und die hatten wir letzten Sitzung
behandelt gibt es auch moralische
Vernunft also die allermeisten würden
zugestehen instrumentelle Vernunft gibt
es das sehen wir alltäglich dass wir
Mittel ergreifen zu einem bestimmten
Zweck unser gesamtes Handeln ist
bestimmt durch instrumentale
Rationalität wenn ich jetzt hier die
Vorlesung halten möchte muss ich schauen
dass alle Dinge stimmen ich muss Mittel
zum Zweck ergreifen das wird von allen
eigentlich zugestanden die Menschen den
Tieren wohl auch aber darüber
diskutieren wir gleich und jetzt ist
halt die Frage über die wir auch
diskutiert haben gibt es auch moralische
Vernunft also von uns die nicht nur sagt
wenn du jetzt ein bestimmtes Ziel hast
dann musst du das machen also das Gebote
ist zum Beispiel in Fall trainiere
zweimal pro Woche
ernähre dich
gut und so weiter und so fort das wären
die imperative aber die würden natürlich
nur für mich gelten und nur für mich in
dieser Situation die würden für mich
nicht dann gelten wenn ich keine Lust
habe einen halben Marathon zu rennen
oder für Leute die vielleicht lieber
Fahrrad fahren die würden diese
imperative so nicht gelten das ist jetzt
mal der Unterschied und jetzt
diskutieren wir mal ein bisschen drüber
ob auch Tiere von uns haben und wenn
also nicht menschliche Tiere und falls
ja was für ein
wir müssen uns nämlich jetzt fragen noch
mal genauer was ist der Unterschied
zwischen hypothetischen und
kategorischen imperativen und so sieht
der gute Mann aus das ist Immanuel Kant
von 1724 bis 1804 vielleicht der
wichtigste
deutschsprachige Philosoph und auch eine
der wenigen Philosophen die wirklich
so alt sind und noch so anerkannt sind
dazu gehören noch Platon Aristoteles
aber sonst gibt's da nicht so viele die
so unstrittig sind ja also was man kann
gesagt hat z.B auch zum Thema Aufklärung
sie kennen das bestimmt alle auf der aus
der Schule noch aufklärung ist der
Ausgang aus der selbstverständlich
Unmöglichkeit dieses Motto das kann man
natürlich auch heute noch anwenden wenn
man sich die digitalen Medien anschauen
ja auch eine digitale Aufklärung kann
man ganz im Sinne von Manuel kann noch
formulieren da ist er irgendwie zeitlos
also ein absoluter Klassiker wie nur
ganz wenige Philosophie und Philosophen
und er hat eben ein Berg geschrieben die
Bewegung zum Mittag Physik der Sitten
und hier schreibt er jetzt alle
imperative Gebieten entweder
hypothetisch oder kategorisch jene die
hypothetischen stellen die praktischen
Notwendigkeit einer möglichen Handlung
als Mittel zu etwas anderem was man will
noch möglich ist dass man es wolle zu
gelangen vor
also das ist die
instrumentelle Vernunft der kategorische
Imperativ würde der sein welche eine
Handlung als für sich selbst ohne
Beziehung auf einen anderen Zweck als
objektiv notwendig vorstellte also nicht
mit Bezug auf einen anderen Zweck
der hypothetische Imperativ trainiere
zweimal pro Woche der ist nur gültig mit
Blick auf einen anderen Zweck nämlich
den konstanz-lauf innerhalb von zwei
Stunden zu schaffen der kategorische
Imperativ der gilt unabhängig von allen
möglichen anderen Zwecken der ist
intrinsisch gültig und ich habe es noch
mal auf die Form gebracht also
hypothetische Imperativ wenn du y
erreichen möchtest dann musst du dafür x
tun und x kann man sich vorstellen wie
eine Menge aus verschiedenen Teilen
imperativen also trainieren sagen pro
Woche wenn er dich gesund und so weiter
und der kategorische Imperativ der würde
lauten Ruhe x unbedingt nicht nur vor
dem Hintergrund von Y von allen
möglichen y sein x gilt einfach absolut
und hier wäre eben nach Kant das
Beispiel lügen nicht
und nicht nur Lüge nicht wenn deine
beste Freundin dich fragt ob der Kuchen
den Sie für dich gebacken hat dir
schmeckt so Lüge in allen möglichen
Situationen niemals lügen ist
intrinsisch schlecht und das gebildete
kategorisch Imperativ und ja das ist
einfach was anderes als wenn ihre
zweimal pro Woche ja diese Imperativ der
hypothetische trainiere 200 pro Woche
der ist einfach nicht kann der hat keine
kategorische Geltung weil er nicht
vernünftigerweise auf alle Subjekte
übertragen werden kann wieder
verallgemeinerbar der da gibt's keinen
Interesse da gibt's keinen Grund dafür
und jetzt hatten wir die Frage gestellt
gibt es jetzt überhaupt sowas wie
kategorische Imperativ also gibt es eine
Vernunft gibt es die praktische Vernunft
instrumentelle von uns ist ja eine Form
von praktische Vernunft die Mittel zum
Zweck zu finden aber gibt es die
praktische Vernunft insofern als sie uns
also uns kategorische imperative
befiehlt
und David Hume hat es verneint der hat
gesagt also die Vernunft die kämpft auch
gar nicht gegen die Aspekte gegen die
Neigung Immanuel Kant hatte die These
gesagt die vertreten ja unsere
praktische Vernunft die kämpft wirklich
gegen unsere Neigung sie schlägt unsere
Neigungen nieder das ist ein Zitat von
Kant also er spricht vom eigentümpel
also der Auffassung dass wir als
Individuen was besonderes sein und
insbesondere Ausnahmen erlauben dürfen
wie zum Beispiel Notlüge das ist nach
Kante Eigentümer oder auch die selbst
die eigene Liebe von sowas spricht er
das ist für ihn negativ weil wir uns da
immer außen haben gestanden vor dem
absoluten Gesetz und nach Kant
werden drückt die Vernunft
diese Neigungen uns individuell
besonders wichtig zu nehmen
auch immer nach Genuss zu streben diese
Neigung werden nach kann durch die
praktische Vernunft bekämpft also die
Affekte die Neigungen die werden durch
die Vernunft eingeschränkt
und das hat David jung bestritten er hat
gesagt das gibt's nicht es gibt keinen
Kampf zwischen Vernunft und Effekt die
haben gar keine Berührungspunkte das ist
in Kategorienfehler und besonders wenn
es eben das hier dieser hat nur es ist
läuft der Vernunft der praktischen nicht
so wieder wenn ich liebe die Zerstörung
der ganzen Welt will als einen Witz in
meinem Finger und das war die
Umfrage gibt es nicht nur instrumentelle
sondern auch moralische Vernunft und die
meisten von ihnen haben gesagt ja es
gibt
moralische Vernunft also 90 Prozent von
ihnen sind der Meinung das ist der
vernünftiger spricht wenn ich lieber den
Untergang der ganzen Welt will als ein
Ritz in meinem Finger
ja der Vision würde das eben bestreiten
jetzt muss man sich eben überlegen
welche Gründe gibt es dafür davon
auszugehen dass die Vernunft auch
moralisch Gebieten kann und nicht nur
instrumentiell ja was ist der Grund und
jetzt will ich ein bisschen näher auf
diesen kategorischen Imperativ eingehen
wir würden uns jetzt gar nicht mit Moral
Begründung befassen weil das macht Herr
Professor Rosenthal in seiner Vorlesung
wir behandeln jetzt nur den
kategorischen Imperativ unter dem
Gesichtspunkt der praktischen Vernunft
nämlich der praktischen Vernunft die
nicht nur instrumentelle Bedeutung hat
sondern die absolute Bedeutung hat und
das ist eben in der Philosophie eine
ganz strittige Frage ob sowas überhaupt
er sagt nämlich es gibt nicht nur ein
hypothetischen Imperativ endlich gibt es
ein Imperativ der ohne irgendeine andere
durch ein gewisses Verhalten zu
erreichen die Absicht hat Marathon 112
Stunden als Bedingung zum Grund zu legen
dieses Verhalten unmittelbar gebietet
also nicht nur mittelbar nicht nur
vermittelte unmittelbar diese Imperativ
ist kategorisch kategorisch heißt ohne
Diskussion ein kategorisches nein
unbedingt das nein oder ja wie auch
immer er betrifft nicht die Materie eine
Handlung also nicht bestimmte Ziele oder
Zwecke und das was aus ihr erfolgen soll
also nicht konsequentialistisch sie
werden das auch noch mitbekommen
konsequentialismus die Folgen einer
Handlung die betrifft der gar nicht es
geht im kategorischen partitiv nicht
darum was die Handlung verfolgen haben
sollte was sollen die Form das Prinzip
woraus sie selbst folgt
also es geht ihm um die Form der
Handlung letztendlich um die Frage ob
die Maxime also der handlungsgrundsatz
ob der sich widerspruchsfrei
verallgemeinern lässt das ist die Form
der Handlung und nicht der Inhalt der
kategorische Imperativ der betrachtet
eigentlich gar nicht konkrete Zwecke und
konkrete Ziele sondern nur die Frage
kann der Grundsatz die Maxime zum
Beispiel ich will mir einen bestimmten
Situation eine Lüge gestatten ob dieser
Grundsatz vernünftigerweise
verallgemeinert werden kann ob dieses
Prinzip der Ausnahme Lüge ob das
wirklich alle vernünftigen Wesen
gleichermaßen gelten kann und Immanuel
Kant würde sagen nein die Form nicht der
Inhalt die Form der Maxine Lüge zu lügen
spricht sich eine Ausnahme zu gestalten
die ist intrinsisch widersprüchlich als
er versucht den kategorischen Imperativ
und dieses kategorisches unbedingt
bedingte eigentlich durch eine Art von
normalitäts- und Kohärenz
widerspruchsprüfung zu erreichen das ist
eigentlich eine logische Sache wir
prüfen nicht jetzt konkrete Zwecke die
wir wollen sind einfach die Form der
Zwecke können wir das was wir wollen
vernünftig verallgemeinern auf alle
Lügen geht es können wir alle dürfen
wollen ist es sinnvoll widersprüchlich
er würde sagen es ist widersprüchig aber
darüber müssen wir noch diskutieren ist
eine Welt von vernünftigen Wesen ihre
Koexistenz denkbar in der alle lügen
dürfen waren immer sie wollt im Handel
kann sagt das wäre nicht möglich und
weil es nicht möglich ist ergibt sich
daraus dass diese Maxime unmoralisch ist
dass sie verboten wird diese Handlung
die Formen das Prinzip woraus ihr folgt
und das wesentlich gute der besteht in
der Gesinnung Gesinnung ist meine Maxime
Gesinnung betrifft nicht die Handlung
sondern die Grundsätze meine Motive die
der Handlung zugrunde liegt das ist das
entscheidende
Erfolg all die folgen mögen sein welche
er wolle dieser imperativmarkt der der
Sittlichkeit heißen also das ist so eine
Beschreibung und jetzt kriegen sie von
mir noch zwei Formeln des kategorisch
Imperativs präsentiert sie haben das
sicherlich auch in der Schule gelernt
der kategorische Imperativ das ist sowas
was man von Kant weiß genauso wie die
Bestimmung der Aufklärung als Ausgang
aus der selbstverschuldenten
Unmöglichkeit so lernt man auch das hier
handle so dass die Maxime deines Willens
Maxim haben wir schon kennengelernt der
subjektive handlungsgrundsatz dass der
jederzeit zugleich als Prinzip eine
allgemeingesetzgebung gelten können also
wir müssen die Maxime
verallgemeinern alle vernünftigen
Subjekte sollten diese Maxime haben
können ohne dass es zu einem Widerspruch
kommt natürlich ist jetzt immer die
Frage was für ein Widerspruch ist es
wenn jetzt alle die Maxime haben ich
darf lügen und ich darf zur Not Lügen
was ergibt sich dafür einen Widerspruch
konkreter aus darüber werden wir gleich
diskutiert ja weil das ist gar nicht
klar zum Beispiel könnte man sagen der
Widerspruch ist es
ja dann
würde mir gerne mit mir glauben das so
könnte man es argumentieren aber warum
könnte man weiter fragen warum was ist
daran so schlimm wenn wir niemand mehr
glaubt es ist mir doch egal ob mir
jemand glaubt oder nicht ja ist doch
kein Widerspruch logische Widersprüche
sind ganz klar die kann ich beweisen
aber kann ich ihn praktischer Hinsicht
Widersprüche überhaupt
erkennen oder kritisieren oder überhaupt
behaupten sinnvoll oder ist es nicht nur
subjektiv was jetzt daran Widerspruch
ist nicht vielleicht wollen ja manche
Menschen immer Lügen und auch belügt
werden ja sie kennt vielleicht den
Spruch was du nicht willst was man Dir
tut auch keinem anderen zu so wird
häufig kannst kategorisch Imperativ
gelesen aber wenn jetzt jemand sagt die
steht total drauf immer angelogen zu
werden da steht total drauf also lüge
ich immer ja dann hätte der keine Geld
Gültigkeit ja oder so also sie können
das beliebig mit anderen Dingen
unmoralischen Dingen auch durchspielen
ich habe jetzt mal die harmlos diese
Form genommen und dann gibt es noch eine
Form also es gibt verschiedene Formeln
des kategorischen Imperativs das ist
noch eine andere das erste war könnte
man denn die
gesetzesformel die allgemeine
gesetzesformel und das zwei die zweite
Formel ist die selbstzweckformel die ist
vielleicht noch wichtig weil die laut so
handelt es so dass du die Menschheit
sowohl in deiner Person als in der
Person eine sie in anderen jederzeit
zugleich als Zweck niemals als bloßes
Mittel gebraucht als der kategorische
Imperativ sagt letztendlich dass es
verboten ist Menschen nach dem
hypothetischen Imperativ zu gebrauchen
das ist der Witz letztendlich ja du
sollst nicht Menschen als Mittel zum
Zwecke brauchen
so wie du eben jetzt als Mittel zum
Zweck
zweimal pro Woche trainieren ja aber
nach dieser Logik sollst du nicht
Menschen
du sollst Menschen nicht
instrumentalisieren und wenn Sie das
Grundgesetz sich mal anschauen die Würde
des Menschen ist unantastbar da werden
Sie feststellen im Grundgesetz da kommt
diese
selbstzweckformel immer mal wieder so
indirekt drin vor also kant hat der
Party gestanden für die Begründung der
Menschenwürde also Menschen würde können
sich ganz leicht zur erklären das ist
einfach das
instrumentalisierungsverbot ja natürlich
werden Menschen sie alle und ich auch
immer wieder in bestimmten Situationen
instrumentalisiert und das ist auch gar
nichts vermeiden zum Beispiel wenn Sie
eine Funktion einnehmen oder eine Rolle
spielen ja ich spiele jetzt hier die
Rolle desjenigen der ihn da was erzählt
und sie spielen jetzt die Rolle der
Studentinnen und Studenten irgendwie
werde ich da instrumentalisiert und sie
vielleicht auch aber das werden wir
jetzt nur hier in diesem Raum nur in
diesen zwei Stunden und dann sind sie
wieder draußen und dann werden sie nicht
mehr instrumentalisiert sofern sie
überhaupt instrumentalisiert werden
sollen ja versuche ich nicht mit ihm zu
machen und ich lass mich auch ungern
instrumentalisieren aber wenn Sie
wenn Sie eine Arbeit nachgehen dann
haben sie
ein Ziel was sie verfolgen müssen da
haben sie eine sind sie weisungsgebunden
sozusagen ja da darf ihre Vorgesetzte
Vorgesetzter ihn schon sagen was jetzt
tun sollten das heißt er oder sie
instrumentalisiert sie aber halt nur
unter dem Gesichtspunkt der Arbeit wenn
die Arbeit vorbei ist dann lassen sie
sich nicht mehr instrumentalisieren und
sie lassen sich auch nicht
ausschließlich instrumentalisieren ihre
Arbeit weil sie lassen sich nur aus
einem bestimmten Gesichtspunkt ist
mentalisieren aber nicht als ganze
Person ne und jetzt diskutieren immer
darüber ein bisschen weil ich habe schon
ein paar Meldung gesehen
wir wollen heute jetzt noch auf das
eigentliche Thema zu sprechen kommen
nämlich Willensschwäche das ist auch ein
Thema was ich immer schon wieder ein
bisschen am Rand erwähnt hatte
was ist jetzt wie man Schwäche das ist
natürlich auch ein Begriff der wie alle
philosophischen Begriffe bisher
kontrovers diskutiert ist manche
bestreiten dass es überhaupt
Willensschwäche gibt das typisch
Philosophie da gibt es jetzt ein Begriff
und manche sagen dann sofort mit guten
Gründen der Begriff ist sinnlos so ist
Philosophie ja wie wäre das eine Physik
Vorlesung wenn jetzt ihn plötzlich der
Begriff der Zeit vorgestellt wird und
alles sagen seit es doch sinnlos ne beim
Raum kann man das jetzt mittlerweile
schon argumentieren weil der Raum häufig
als ergänze Eigenschaft von Zeit
aufgefasst wird also etwas abgeleitet
ist in der Physik kann man noch
spekulieren aber in anderen
Wissenschaften geht es nicht so sehr wie
in der Philosophie also Willensschwäche
betrifft das Verhältnis von uns Willen
und unserem Wissen und Behandlung und es
gibt da offenbar ein Missverhältnis
zwischen diesen drei Bestandteilen weil
in wir tun wenn wir wildschwach sind so
die klassische Definition wir tun nicht
das wofür die meisten besten Gründe
sprechen also wir tun nicht das wovon
wir eigentlich praktisches Wissen
erworben haben ja unsere Überzeugung
aber wir handeln sagt man auch wieder
besseres Wissen ja
wir wissen es eigentlich es ist so und
so das ist die beste Option
wir haben eigentlich gute Gründe ja
wieder normative Aspekt des Grundes ja
ein guter Grund und trotzdem
Erfolg unsere Handlung nicht
dementsprechend und das ist etwas ja
paradox weil wir sollten doch nach all
dem was jetzt in uns enthalten ist
danach handelt deswegen gibt es ein
Verwandter Begriff
Unbeherrschtheit wird häufig auch
verwandt
aggressia ist das griechische Wort und
das können sie immer wieder zerlegen a
bedeutet nicht das ist das Alpha
privatierung also die Beraubung von
etwas sie kennen das alles die Asymptote
das ist das was nie das ganze berührt ne
es nähert sich unendlich an alles
griechische mit dem Eis eine Verneinung
und die Rasierer das ist
quatschi kennen sie Demokratie das ist
also die unbeherrscht hat so können sich
das Wort erklären
aggressivheit also Willen schwach sind
Personen dann wenn sie auch irgendwie
unbeherrscht sind wenn sie praktisch
nicht den besten gründen
sind folgen oder ihrem Wissen folgen
wenn also das Wissen nicht irgendwie
handlungswirksam wird wenn im Inneren
Gefüge uns Vermögen die Koordination
einfach fehlt wenn wir nicht ganz
einheitlich handeln können und das ist
natürlich immer ideal kann man wieder
sagen Normativität eine ideal unser
Handeln sollte normalerweise einheitlich
sein das heißt wenn wir die besten
Gründe gefunden haben wenn wir das Beste
Wissen erlangt haben dann sollte das
Wissen normativ sein also normative
Gründe dann sollten wir aber nach
handeln aber es scheint zumindest sagen
das einige Philosophen und Philosophen
Situation zu geben wo wir trotzdem diese
Dinge vorliegen nicht danach handeln das
heißt Willensschwäche bedeutet das Wille
und Vernunft nicht
übereinstimmen es gibt ja ein Konflikt
und man kann deswegen Willensschwäche
als eine Form von praktischer
Irrationalität Paket bezeichnet ich habe
deswegen jetzt Willensschwäche dem Thema
praktische Vernunft folgen lassen können
sich denken weil einmal hatten das von
praktischer Rationalität
Gründe war davor Gründe sind ja auch was
irgendwie gibt rationale Gründe und
jetzt machen wir eben dann alte
alternativ dazu
praktische Irrationalität wir wollen
immer auch schauen wie kann es eben auch
schief gehen ja Handel funktioniert
leider nicht immer sondern kann auch mal
daneben gehen und das ist etwa dann der
Fall wenn es sich um willensliche
handelt und man kann sagen handeln
könnte irrational genannt werden wenn
wir unmoralisch haben wir haben noch
eine eigene das Böse das ist aber auch
noch ein riesen Thema als man sollte
Willensschwäche oder akasie unabhängig
von
unmoralischen Handlung behandeln als
unmoralische Behandlung sind nicht
dasselbe wie brillenschwache Handlung
obwohl sie manchmal im Kopf geworfen
werden ja darüber kann man natürlich
auch diskutieren wir werden halt auch
noch ein bisschen diskutieren ich möchte
jetzt aber noch bevor wir diskutieren
auf eine ganz wirkmächtige
Position
Eingehen von Donald dailson Donald
Davidson ist ein US-amerikanischer
Philosoph vom ähnlichen Kaliber wie
Harry Frank wird Harry Frank wird habe
ich ihn vorgestellt das sind sogenannte
analytische Philosophen man nennt die
analytische Philosophen weil sie eben
sich ganz speziellen sachproblemen
widmen also systematischen Problemen
analytische Philosophie wird in Konstanz
sehr prominent Betrieben analytische
Philosophie meint man geht nicht dass er
auf die Geschichte ein und interpretiert
oder legt die Geschichte aus sondern
konzentriert sich mehr auf das Problem
und schaut wie wurde es vielleicht von
verschiedenen Philosophen Philosoph
behandelt aber im Zentrum steht das
Problem das Problem und Donald David
Frank wird auch ein sogenannte
analytischer Philosoph und er hat einen
Aufsatz geschrieben
natürlich ursprünglich Englisch
erschienen in der deutschen Übersetzung
von 1970 als es der erschienen lautet
der Titel wie ist Willensschwäche
möglich da sehen sie da wird einfach ein
systematisches Problem willenschwäche
ins Zentrum gestellt ihm geht's nicht
darum was Aristoteles über
willenschwäche gesagt hat oder
vielleicht kalt es wäre dann eher so die
kontinentale Herangehensweise häufig
setzt man Continental und analytisch
entgegen was die Philosophie Methode
anbelangt ich bin aber nicht der Meinung
dass diese Entgegensetzung überzeugend
ist also kontinentale Philosophie wird
häufig mit der europäischen Philosophie
Frankreich Deutschland Österreich so
verbunden das sei ihr historisch
orientiert und die analytische
Philosophie dieser er sagt problematisch
orientiert die würde im angelsächsischen
Bereich betrieben also Großbritannien
USA das war vielleicht in einer gewissen
Zeit gab es diesen Gegensatz aber
heutzutage bitte immer mehr überwunden
jedenfalls Sonne Davidson zu
traditionellerweise der analytischen
systematischen Philosophie zugerechnet
und er sagt jetzt folgendes in diesem
Aufsatz der Wille eine handelnde Person
ist schwach sofern sie ihren eigenen
bestmöglichen Urteil zu widerhalten und
zwar absichtlich zu wieder hat
in solchen Fällen heißt es mit unter dem
Handelnden Fehler die nötige
Willenskraft um zu tun was nach seinem
Wissen oder zumindest nach seiner
Überzeugung und bei Berücksichtigung
aller Umstände das bessere wäre also das
Interessante ist hier
dass er absichtlich er oder sie
absichtlich den bestmöglichen Urteils
wieder hat nicht nur einfach so ich habe
so ein Denkfehler begangen also ich bin
jetzt halt so ein Urteil gekommen und im
Nachhinein sehe ich das Urteil war
einfach das falsche Urteil ich habe
nicht genug nachgedacht ja hat nicht die
besten Gründe gefunden ich habe
irgendwann aufgehört die Gewichten
sondern ich habe für mich eigentlich das
beste Urteil gefällt und ich handle ihm
absichtlich also wieder besseres Wissen
kann also sehenden Auge handle ich ihm
wieder
wenn jemand unter Berücksichtigung aller
Umstände als ein weiteres Zitat eine
Handlungsweise für die beste hält bzw
für die richtige unter allen Umständen
meint wir haben wirklich alle Optionen
Erwägung gezogen es hängt nicht damit
zusammen dass ich nicht genug
nachgedacht hat ja sondern ich habe alle
Optionen berücksichtigt bzw das richtig
oder das was er tun sollt und trotzdem
etwas anderes tut dann handelt er
unbeherrscht sie sind der akasie ich
würde allerdings auch sagen er handele
unbeherrscht sofern er eine verfügbare
Handlungsweise verbesser hält als
diejenige für die er sich entscheidet
oder sofern er in Bezug auf das
Verhältnis zwischen einer anderen
Handlungsweise dir vermutlich hält und
wer von ihm ausgeführten Handlung zu dem
Urteil kommt er sollte die andere
Handlung vollziehen und es interessiert
jetzt nur der erste Bereich hier es geht
um die Berücksichtigung aller Umstände
eine Handlungsweise die wird für die
beste gehalten und trotzdem
gerade trotzdem tut er etwas anders also
sehenden Auges nicht selbst täuschen
oder so sondern da ist es
eigentlich sollte ich das tun sagt mir
meine Vernunft praktische von uns und
trotzdem tue ich was anderes das andere
ja
und jetzt gibt er hier eine Definition
und da sehen sie immer wieder typisch
analytische Philosophie so sieht
analytische Philosophie aus da kommen
immer ganz viele x hervor also
analytische Philosophie ist immer
formalisierend ein bisschen formalisiert
also
möglichst logisch eindeutig ja in dem
der handelte
x tut handelt er dann und nur dann
unbeherrscht wenn das ist ein typisch
analytischer philosophischer Satz so
argumentieren Analytikerin und
Analytiker dann und nur dann ja also
ganz möglichst präzise wenn A der
handelte x absichtlich tot
also X ist eine beliebige Handlung ist
eine Variable B die handelnde glaubt
eine Alternative Handlung y sein möglich
weil es kann ja auch sein ich weiß
praktisch dass
X nicht die beste Option ist aber eine
andere Option ist nicht möglich ja aber
hier geht es noch eine andere Option und
C die handelnde urteilt das unter
Berücksichtigung alle Umstände die
Ausführung von Y besser wäre als die
Ausführung von x
ja das ist jetzt so die Definition also
X ist nicht die beste Option muss ich
noch ein bisschen korrekter fassen X ist
nicht die beste Handlung weil nämlich y
ist die beste Handlung
und
obwohl x getan wird oder x wird getan
obwohl die Person weiß dass
unter Berücksichtigung alle Umstände
alle Gründe für Y
sprechen ja also die Waage schlägt die
gründewaage schlägt eindeutig aus y und
trotzdem tue ich x und zwar absichtlich
so und jetzt würde ich gerne mit Ihnen
noch ein bisschen diskutieren gibt's den
konkrete Fälle haben Sie konkrete also
erstmal gibt es überhaupt sowas wie
dieses beschriebene Phänomen weil das
ist ja schon ziemlich starkes Stück ja
unterwegs in Bedingungen könnten wir
sowas wie
aggressiv überhaupt sinnvollerweise
annehmen ja
also wir haben gesehen diese
Charakterisierung der Willensschwäche
der akrasie ist hochgradig umstritten
wie eigentlich vieles auch eine
Philosophie gibt es konkrete Phänomen
die darunter fallen in der nächsten
Sitzung will ich mit Ihnen diskutieren
das Thema Handlungsfreiheit also jetzt
gehen wir so langsam über nachdem wir
die Grundbegriffe geklärt haben
Handlungen Wille
Rationalität Irrationalität
gehen wir jetzt über auf den
Freiheitsbegriff ja jetzt merken sie
wird das Ganze so langsam verbunden ich
werde ihn auch ein begriffsnetz zu
schicken demnächst vielleicht übers
Wochenende wo sie mal unsere bisher
kennengelernten Begriffe auch grafisch
in Verbindungslinien sehen
Handlungsfreiheit häufig unterscheidet
man gar nicht zwischen
freiheitsbedeutung weiter wir sind frei
oder wir sind unfrei und da möchte ich
Ihnen im Rahmen dieser Vorlesungen noch
mehr Informationen geben also
Handlungsfreiheit bedeutet tun zu können
was man will ich will etwas ich habe in
mir ein Ziel ein Zweck ein Wunsch was
auch immer und ich kann das tun was ich
will das Handlungsfreiheit
und man muss handlungsfrei unterscheiden
von der Willensfreiheit Willensfreiheit
bedeutet und das ist ein bisschen
paradox vom Leben wir machen
Willensfreiheit in der Sitzung darauf
also im nächsten Donnerstag nächsten
Mittwoch machen wir Handlungsfreiheit
nächsten Donnerstag
Willensfreiheit wäre dagegen wollen
können was man will
und das ein bisschen paradox wenn ich
was will dann will ich doch was wieso
muss ich das was ich will noch mal
wollen können es reicht doch dass ich
was will und dass ich dann tun kann dann
bin ich noch frei warum sollte man den
Willen selbst noch mal reflektieren
können das wird dann wieder zu Harry
Frank wird zurück
Frank wird hat eine Theorie der
Willensfreiheit unseren Willen zu bilden
seconditions ja
Handlungsfreiheit bedeutet wir haben ein
Willen und wir stellen den Willen nicht
in Frage der Wille wird gesetzt und dann
interessiert uns nur die Frage können
wir das tun was wir
es gibt eine riesendebatte in der
Philosophie manche sagen Willensfreiheit
ist völlig ausreichend für unsere
Freiheit wir brauchen eine
Handlungsfreiheit ist völlig ausreichend
für unsere Freiheit wir brauchen gar
nicht Willensfreiheit ist viel zu viel
verlangt unseren Willen noch zu wollen
aber es reicht wenn es soweit tun zu
können was man will also
Handlungsfreiheit genügt sagen viele
andere sagen das genügt nicht wir müssen
noch einen anspruchsvolleren
Freiheitsbegriff voraussetzen nämlich
Willen wieder eine riesen Debatte was
spricht dafür Willensfreiheit noch zu
fordern oder genügt nicht schon
handlungsfrei wir werden uns aber
nächstes mal erst mal mit
Handlungsfreiheit befassen und dazu
werde ich Ihnen einen Text geben von
John Lock der ist auch ein englisches
aus dem 18 Jahrhundert der hat eine ganz
prominente Theorie der Handlungsfreiheit
der willenfreiheit formuliert und die
Handlungsfreiheit behandeln wir wieder
anhand von Harry Frank fährt dann
wünsche ich Ihnen jetzt noch eine schöne
Restwoche und viel Spaß beim
Philosophieren